You've probably heard of flashlights that never need batteries or replacement bulbs. This is too good to be true
[I] really [wanted] to know so today [I] decided to build my own
To start I bought an economy flashlight for a dollar [49] then I broke it down to its components
After removing the [parts]. I didn't need, I cut a piece of [1-inch] PVC pipe and wrapped it with insulated Magnet wire
Next [I] found a rubber bouncy ball and split it in half to plug the ends of the Tube
before sealing off the top I placed inside a three quarter inch by one inch neodymium rare-Earth Magnet [I]
Used an open flame from my barbecue igniter to remove the coating from the ends of the wires
Then I hooked the exposed ends to my multimeter to test it out
I was surprised that when I shook the tube it easily generated an alternating current of over four volts
To prevent damage to the rest of the wire coating I wrapped some packing tape twice around the Tube
This also helped keep the wire in place and keep the Tube snug in the casing
Next I drew up a schematic for the circuit. I would need and I went to work soldering and twisting wires in Place. [I]
Use a FULL BRIDGE Recifyer!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
I found on a junk circuit board to convert the Ac from the shaker directly to DC.
I Wired this to a five and a half volt one farad electrolytic capacitor that I found on the same board
Next I wired a rocker switch that I hoped would fit in the pre-existing switch hole and luckily it did
I Carefully packed all the components inside the casing and left just the two lead wires hanging out
For convenience in changing out future leds. [I] soldered an eight pin Ic socket to the positive and negative lead wires
Then I hot glued it to the underside of the reflector, and the fit couldn't have been better
To finish up I inserted a 10 millimeter white led that I got at Radioshack for about three dollars
I Screwed the cap back on and done my very own shake flashlight.
I Tested it out and was amazed at the results
Not only was the light bright, but for just 30 seconds of shaking [I] could use my light for over 10 minutes
Well, I guess that answers the question that yes
You can run a flashlight without batteries as long as you're willing to get a workout at the same time
That's another item for my emergency kit
And it was a lot of fun to make I hope you've enjoyed watching this video as much as I've enjoyed making it
Thanks for [watching]